c'est une manifestation de gilet jaune
manifestations qui avaient lu depuis
plusieurs semaines étant donné que le
préfet l'allemand avait un malin plaisir
à interdire les manifestations contraire
à au gouvernement et donc ce jour là je
me dirigeais avec deux amis qui sont à
côté de moi sur la photo est juste avant
d'arriver au lieu de rassemblement nous
avons été bloqué par un groupe de
policiers qui étaient casqués cuirasse
et armés de boucliers et donc ils ont
ils nous ont interdit d'accéder aux
lieux de rassemblement donc si vous
voulez c'était déjà une preuve de du
fait de bafouer la liberté
constitutionnelle de circuler de
manifester et c'est une des raisons qui
explique à ce moment là que j'étais
effectivement très énervé de voir ces
policiers qui nous empêchait d'accéder
au lieu de alors on va revoir la vidéo
mais après je pense qu'ils sont dit on
aurait mieux fait de laisser passer
parce que là c'est là là là ça c'est
qu'ils ont prié regarder
d'un camion macro
alors ça thérèse entendu dans le public
alors où est ce que tout ça est ce que
tu peux déjà précisé que ça c'est le
slogan donc spontanée qui m'est venue à
la bouche à la fin de la diatribe que
j'avais spontanément fait oui à dire que
juste avant vous avez quand même deux
minutes où j'explique pourquoi ils
macron je le considère comme un
dictateur et comme un individu
criminelle pendant les dix pendant les
deux minutes précédant est-ce que vous
pouvez nous l'eau est ce que vous pouvez
nous dire pourquoi l'or ben justement
par exemple pendant les deux minutes
précédentes je parle de du coup d'état
de macron le 16 mars 2020 quand il a
assigné à résidence sans aucune raison
et alors que ce n'est pas dans ses
attributions quand il assigne à
résidence des millions de français et de
français je parle aussi du décret
rivotril qui a été pris par son premier
ministre et par son ministre de la santé
le 28 mars 2020 et qui permet à des
médecins généralistes d'injecter un
médicament qui est contre indiquée pour
la détresse respiratoire de l'injecter à
des personnes qui ont été soit des
dossiers qu'ovide soit susceptible
d'avoir le covin et ces personnes ont
sont en état de détresse respiratoire et
le rivotril va les faire
partir beaucoup plus vite alors parle de
cela je parle de ça et je parle aussi et
ensuite vous n'êtes pas prêt vous partez
dans la diatribe sur macron voilà mais
ça c'est la diatribe et je parle aussi
et c'est pour ça que suis très contente
d'avoir madame rosen à mes côtés je
parle aussi de du bâillon qui a été
imposé à 12 millions d'élèves à partir
de l'automne 2020 étant donné que je
suis moi même enseignante de 30 en jeu
je comprends que c'est une maltraitance
et donc c'est tout ça si vous voulez
plus le contexte parce qu'il faut pas il
faut pas oublier que pendant que je
parle j'ai à ma gauche un cordon de
policiers qui empêchent une cinquantaine
de citoyennes et citoyens d'accéder aux
lieux de rassemblement et c'est ça qui a
fait qu'effectivement j'ai lancé ce
slogan tout à fait spontané il ya une
partie si vous voulez historique dans ce
slogan c'est à dire que destitution pour
moi c'était une évocation de du procès
de lui s'insurge été jugées sur le mou
décapitation pour moi c'était historique
s'était faite après la condamnation de
macron si jamais un jour comme je
l'espère y passe en or au tribunal eh
bien deux ruelles à la peine de mort
pour certains individus et j'attends
peut-être que vous me posez la question
à ce que je regrette aujourd'hui d'avoir
dit ce mot
parce que je n'avais pas compris à
l'époque si vous voulez que beaucoup de
gens ne comprendraient pas tout de suite
la référence historique l'homme s'était
présent dans mon esprit et surtout
surtout il y a eu quelques semaines
après le meurtre abominable d'un autre
sur saignement ça mais elle pâtit donc
il est évident qu'aujourd'hui je ne re
dirigera du tout c'est bien c'est bien
de le dire ça franchement c'est très
bien de dire et je veux dire aux
cyclones que quand je dis aussi à la fin
il faut lui exposer la gueule à ce
dictateur c'est aussi effectivement un
moment de colère de ma part qui gelé
compris après coup
dessert tout ce que j'avais piqué le
regretter jocelyne ce soir tard dit il
faudrait que ces dictateurs oui parce
que comment est la vulgarité ne sert pas
un peu dit il alors que vous l'avez la
vulgarité mahdi 14
heures que ça merde c'est vulgaire je
réponds à virtua vulgarité du propos il
faut l'expo la gueule je ne suis pas
vulgaire j'ai été bien éduqué par mes
parents alors pour l'instant je réponds
alors je suis jocelyne aaa a été
condamné à trois mois de prison avec
sursis vous vous comprenez pas ça non je
comprends pas cette condamnation n'est
totalement injuste et le manque
profondément d'humanité sur cette vidéo
on voit une femme qui en colère qui en
détresse elle s'attaquait magnanac mot
évidemment le symbole pas l'être humain
et je trouve que cette dessert emmanuel
macron aujourd'hui en tant que candidat
s'appelle symbole que les gens qui
s'attaquent à lui il les attaque lui de
manière permanente alors que d'autres
candidats par an comme eric zemmour lui
prend le temps d'échanger avec les
personnes qui s'en prennent à lui parce
que souvent il ya une histoire derrière
par eric zemmour quand on sait très
content bah oui là ils attaquent
systématiquement les gens qui s'en
prennent à lui et à d'autres candidats
qui prennent le nerd et changer ce qui
l'a été par l'internet qui a joué à neuf
alors qu'il appartient à l'histoire
guerrière premium
je tiens quand même à préciser
combien en effet que c'est un peu
injuste comme condamnation mais je sais
qu'à préciser que même à mâcon n'a pas
porté plainte et acheteurs enfin la
procureur de chalons en champagne qui
s'appelle my j ai décidé de porter
plainte contre moi c'est ça dans le
cadre d'une autre affaire et c'est pour
ça que je suis venu aussi monsieur
hanouna c'est pour parler de l'autre
infractions qui lui étaient reprochées
qui est mille fois plus importante à mes
yeux c'est quoi
le prétendu outrage à deux institutrices
qui colle à moi demain je me jette en
faute professionnelle était en faute
professionnelle selon avoir gardé
masquer une cinquantaine d'élèves 50 ans
qu'elle leur faisait faire des activités
physiques et score fait en trois élèves
sont elles monsieur vous avez insultés
briderait sont venus pour parler aussi
de sept secondes à faire alors on va en
parler j'ai répondu que je répondrai à
monsieur donc emma l'huma qu'on n'a pas
porté plainte contre moi il n'avait pas
porté plainte non plus contre le
monsieur qui lui a donné une gifle et
c'est vraiment la procureure qui a
décidé de lier les deux affaires et elle
a peut être pensé comme il n'y avait pas
de témoins
lorsque j'ai interpellé les deux
institutrices qui était en faute
professionnelle quand revel a peut-être
pensé que cela ferait croire à la
présidente du tribunal alors que j'avais
parlé aux deux ya des gens qui vient la
même façon il ya des gens qui sont je
dois je vais vous donner la parole la
diren gens qui dit qu il est relou monty
bernard montiel savent a dit regretter
il veut quoi de plus cela alors non je
trouve ça très bien et parce que normal
qu'elle regrette et j'apprécie que vous
regardiez vos propos je dis simplement
que quand vous avez insultés vos
collègues y avait quand même ça dépend
si téméraire et mâcon vous n'êtes pas au
courant monsieur apparemment j'ai lu le
doubs n'est pas au courant la bo de
vichy avoir lieu de cheveux parce que le
dossier a été uniquement transmis mon
avocat donc vous n'êtes pas au courant
des deux infractions totale parce que je
lui conservant le monde et où si vous
étiez au courant vous sauriez au mode
avril 2021 ont-ils la procureure avait
d'abord cherché à m'accuser d'injures
envers un corps constitué de
fonctionnaires ce qu'elle a abandonné
par la suite dit oui parce que les deux
institutrices ont bien dit que je ne
savais pas injurier et que je les avais
pas insulter donc monsieur vous feriez
mieux de vous renseigner avant
d'affirmer que moi je compte y est vrai
qu'on reste sur le sujet bernard montiel
là c'est bon comprenez vous qu'une gilet
jaune été condamné trois mois de prison
avec sursis
veut un oui géraldine banier alors
d'abord madame moi j'entends absolument
votre exaspération votre colère le
sentiment de ne pas être écouté des
trous en tout cas d'être injustement
traités et moi je peux très bien
comprendre qu'on sort de ses gonds en
revanche je n'entends enfin c'est quoi
les gilet jaune pour vous alors parce
que vous nous parler depuis tout à
l'heure que du vaccin que du paf madame
je ne sais pas le mot valeurs évoluent
dans votre bouche c'est l'instant je
n'ai jamais prendre les armes on est
encore maigre pas beaucoup de mines vous
devez poser une question me prenez-vous
qu'une gilet jaune a été condamné à
trois mois de prison oui avec sursis
pour m'apprendre cabaye et matuidi
douleur match quoi oui pourquoi madame
jourdain vos regrets et très bien mais
pour le reste pardon ce que j'ai
entendus me fait honte vous êtes une ans
et vous faites cela vous donnera vous
fait honte à vous oui vraiment madame
vous êtes chez moi vous dire madame
madame china moses est une enseigne en
enseignants personnels monsieur omelette
une enseignante vous représentez la
république vous représentez vos élèves
et vous crier comme ça au président
décapitation vous criez dictateur ou est
bon que vous devriez connaître parce que
vous êtes enseignante à moi c'est moi
mais je fais tu ne vous avez dit et vous
méritez vraiment ces trois mois avec
sursis pour montrer de 13,4 tous vos
nerfs dès que les gens qui se comportent
comme vous et les montrent un sens ça
devrait en avoir un dans votre tête vous
êtes enseignante madame étaient mes mots
ont un sens ce que vous avez fait c'est
une honte eh bien monsieur satie laisser
parler je suis vous avez votre opinion
d'accord vous la gardez pour vous ok ben
on m'a demandé de mentionner monsieur
l'abbé visiblement
c'est madame est en tout cas pour parler
de la condamnation monsieur hanouna vous
m'avez pas posé la question si moi je
trouvais en anecdotes drôles d'accord
donc je n'ai pas encore décidé avec mon
avocat si je ferai appel d'accord ici je
fais appel ça sera dans le cadre de la
deuxième infraction mais pas de celle ci
la première elle est juste cordes et
excusez moi vous me couper la parole à
chaque fois où je peux répondre à
monsieur hanouna parce que c'est pas
clair vous me couper la parole à chaque
fois
des dogon au moins maintenant
je fais j'ai été agressive à rennes on
va les séparer
merci passionnés merci d'arrêter merci
oui donc je tiens à préciser que
l'audience au tribunal de châlons en
champagne hier s'est passé parfaitement
est tout à fait correctement et je
remercie la présidente du tribunal
d'avoir mené cette audience une façon
absolument correcte j'ai parfaitement
compris le comment dire
le contexte dans lequel se situer ce
jugement étant donné que je pense et je
la firme de nouveau que depuis le 16
mars 2020 nous ne sommes pas dans un
état de droit je ne pense pas qu'une
autre condamnation aurait pu être aurait
pu être possible je ne constate la
relaxe aurait pu être possible mon
avocat me l'avait dit et je pense que
c'est une condamnation suffisamment
clémente qui a pris en compte ce que
j'ai dit à l'audience c'est à dire que
c'était un slogan historique et aux
politiques lancer effectivement dans un
moment où j'étais hors de mes goûts
trois mois de prison avec sursis ou pas
pardon est ce que c'est sévère pour vous
trois mois de prison avec sursis non je
pense que si je mens je pense que c'est
assez clément et je veux dit génial et
je ne veux pas penser que la parfaite
elle et je vous le dis
je c'est fini aussi et donc si je fais
appel de ce jugement quand vous battez
là c'est le connais pas et si
on n'est pas bonne à dire si je suis de
côté quand même
on n'est pas aux élèves on n'est pas en
4e année les invités et ça sera pas
tellement pour en effet le la menace de
mort g la présidente a bien compris ce
que j'avais dit la procureure aussi
puisqu'elle ne m'a pas cuisiner donc l a
bien compris le ce que j'avais expliqué
du slogan historico-politique l a bien
compris que le mot décapitation était
une révérence une référence à la
guillotine après un jugement puisque je
rappelle quand même nom mais j'espère
que tout le monde le sait ici aussi
monsieur que louis saez a été jugée
et donc la prison talent parfois
elle m'a simplement dit que je n'avais
pas à prononcer ce genre de ce genre de
propos parce qu'effectivement vue là la
viralité de la vidéo que je ne
soupçonnais pas parce que ce n'est pas
moi qui me suis filmé et bien cela
pouvait comment dire influencer
certaines personnes ce que je n'assure
que je comprends parfaitement et encore
une fois ce mot là bien sûr a été
prononcé plusieurs semaines avant le
meurtre de sa matrice vous êtes d'accord
avec matthew avec mathieu ouais alors
pas du tout je suis comme madame je ne
cautionne pas ce qu'elle a dit mais elle
même ne le cautionne pas et a dit
qu'elle ne leur dirai pas elle dit même
qu'on est dans un état de droit qu'elle
a été jugée elle ne sait pas si elle va
faire appel donc voilà cc c'est vraiment
une très bonne attitude alors j'ose il a
été révoqué n'est plus proche depuis
2002 puis double c'est c'est une comment
dire étant donné que cette révocation
gelé déjà contesté à deux reprises est
actuellement le deuxième recours
contentieux est toujours en instance
c'est pourquoi en fait ok parce que
depuis 2016 j'ai dénoncée par toutes les
étapes des lanceurs d'alert c'est à dire
en interne puis jusqu'au ministère puis
par la presse j'ai dénoncé le
harcèlement moral verticales et
horizontales dans l'éducation nationale
qui est un véritable fléau ça c'est
autre chose mais c'est intéressant aussi
et parce que justement j'ai utilisé les
armes du droit dans ce combat depuis
2016 contre le rectorat de reims eh bien
je suis devenu un petit peu dangereuse
où ces avancées à faire un truc assez
habile sur un micro louis s'éclipsa à
moi c'est pas nous ce que je voulais
dire c'est que nous ici on arrivait ça
remue on a toujours soutenu les gilets
jaunes pour quand même le savoir et
cyril a été le premier chéri alsace et
qui montre moi qui sais c'est vous
c'est qu'il sait benoît merci
heureusement que tu es là mon chéri
disais vous savez qu'ici et cyril a été
un des premiers à soutenir les gilet
jaune et nous aussi on a très bien
compris la colère des gilet jaune donc
c'est pas le problème des gilet jaune
moi ce qui me choque ce sont alors moi
je te sais très bien que vous
reconnaissiez que vous avez dit vous
avez été trop loin et que vous le
regrettez qu'elle dit que le jugement
est clément oui oui
et c'est cette fois avec sursis bon ça
ça va puis c'est surtout monsieur je le
répète puisque c'est un hommage que je
rends à la présidente du tribunal
l'audience s'est passé parfaitement aux
normes et c'est très bien et ça c'est la
justice j'ai pu exprimer tout ce que
c'est génial à le président macron qui
vous à cap apporté plein d'entre vous
dans la revoilà la fin du coup c'est la
procureure homélie
alors en revanche ce qui reste choquant
madame ce sont les mots les propos que
vous avez tenus bon maintenant vous les
regrettés et j'apprécie que voulait
regrette-t-il en tout cas j'ai compris
et je vous le redis de nouveau au cas où
certains ou certaines n'auraient pas
compris que pour un discours politique
la vulgarité ne sert à rien j'ai bien
l'emprise de la et sa masse et vous
laisser quelque part je ne savais pas
qu'il y avait un monsieur qui me file
mis d'accord je ne savais pas qu'une
fois qu'il aurait posté sa vidéo sur sa
page facebook elle serait devenue virale
mais quelque part ça m'a rendu service
parce qu'effectivement je me suis rendu
compte que il faut vraiment avoir un
langage clair et surtout pas vulgaire
pour pouvoir expliquer à des millions de
françaises et français qui n'ont pas
encore compris comme le monsieur s'est
assis à ma droite que nous sommes depuis
le 16 mars de vous vous avez comme ils
s'appellent lui oui j'ai cru comprendre
ça plait messieurs delormeau
effectivement un langage un langage
clair
de leurs journées d'été des verts raison
le message vient d'ailleurs comme là bas
c'est vrai qu'ils sont pressés là je
trouvais je trouve que ce que disaient
ils signent ce soit oui après on pense
mais là elle dit qu'elle re que le juge
unique et non franchement je trouve que
c'est bien de l'avoir à mais je suis en
face prévient je la bois travaux de
géraldine mallet la bombe et à bercy
prouve qu'il ya une surenchère de la
violence mais à tous les rouages il ya
deux films violents ce faire les vendent
à mal de quelle violence parlez vous de
la via della verbal vous savez que
oignons jury la violence est uniquement
les atteintes aux biens et aux personnes
vous le savez madame nos médias vous le
savez
et si on parle de violence envers des
biens et des personnes mais dame avait
raison il me semble il me semble et je
remercie monsieur hanouna si
effectivement
il maintenant je sais quand même des
centaines de personnes qui ont perdu
leurs mains ou qui ont perdu leur oeil
ou qui ont eu le crâne fracassé et
c'était violent cela que vous donnez
donc raison
jean cyr animalière de violence verbale
à tous les niveaux aussi bien la classe
politique que certains citoyens que de
certains gilet jaune extrême et sont
rares et heureusement mais moi ce que je
voudrais savoir c est ce qu'aujourd'hui
vous continuez à dire que macro est un
diktat tout à fait mais je reviendrai
quand même je reviendrai juste avant et
jean bourrel a menti c'est un diktat
tout à fait alors qu'il n'a pas de goût
mais jusqu'à vendredi et c'est le seul
jeu peu évident digne et à mesure et
pour dire quoi que j'avais terminé à
nous de répondre parce que ça me paraît
peut finir mais vous rêvez convoyage
lorsque je peux finir de vous répondront
et indique à ce que je peux venir de
vous répondre sur georges peut finir
dans son combat contre tous la même
incroyable alger le faire si tu es là
merci messieurs alors vous avez dit que
toute violence verbale et surtout de
leurs fins même de la part de
personnalités politiques j'espère que
vous aurez remarqué je ne sais pas si
vous l'avez dit sur ce plateau que vous
le condamniez que madame pécresse a dit
en sortant d'un débat télévisé avec
monsieur zemmour il ne faut pas prendre
de gants blancs avec monsieur zemmour je
les truies et maintenant je vais tuer
madame le pen vous en souvenez je pense
que je sais pas si vous en avez parlé si
on n'a pas parlé mon sens la
question
mais je suis d'accord a maintenant la
pression sur le dictateur dictateur
monsieur marc roy est donc un gros
milliard et un moment donné monsieur
macron étaient offusqués que justement
ce mot de dictature apparaissent dans
les légales contre les dangers a dit il
a dit mais c'est pas possible non non la
france n'est pas une dictature une
dictature c'est quand une personne
décide de tout seul d'imposer quelque
chose à des millions de personnes il a
dit cela or c'est ce qu'il a fait le 16
mars 2020
contre vous madame vous savez monsieur
que les procureurs
vous savez que les procureurs en charge
monsieur vous savez il a appelé en outre
savait que nicole belloubet en septembre
2019 mais si vous ne savez pas je
voulais
à une radio à faire lapsus révélateur
petit mais procureur
et comme il s'est aperçu que son astuce
justement risque est de faire comprendre
à des millions de personnes
qu'effectivement les procureurs
aujourd'hui de la république ne sont pas
de vraiment istres à eau mais sans
débordements je parle des pannes à ça
alors ça passait par des problématiques
qui
au contraire au contrat ils sont
totalement indépendants roulage à faire
passer en plus aux coureurs de la
république ans et pas avec son manager
du match messi à ouvrir et voltaire mais
pour mort et cela a été dit par une as
par un arrêt de la cour européenne des
droits humains il pourrait prendre la
version km génère dès que j'ai peur
d'être répondre à votre question
extrêmement
le 16 mars 2020 emmanuel martin
je réponds que je suis le 16 mars 2020
emmanuel macron alors que ce n'est pas
dans ses attributions du président de la
république a assigné à résidence
c'est-à-dire à emprisonner des millions
de françaises et de français sur le
prétexte d'un soi disant qu'on a virus
qui serait comme l'a fait son beurre
ces bandits d'un soi disant pour la
virus qui se veulent comme la peste
noire
essayez madame est servie de contrôle et
vous vous dites des choses essayer maman
revient sur les bons j'ai essayé de
prendre tous les maux et de l'école des
loisirs de voir votre
par la queue macron est un dictateur que
la journée des femmes
il avait des français j'espère que
j'avais répété je suis à côté de lui
mais apparemment il est peut-être son
oreille gauche qui est un peu bouché
de la république en france monsieur ne
sont pas des magistrats au vrai sens du
terme voilà ce que j'ai on va dans 15 et
je vous attendrai la décision de la cour
européenne des droits humains qui
merci aller plus loin s'ils savaient
pour qui vous allez voter ou pas macron
[Rires]
emmanuel macron au premier tour je vois
je voterai pour un candidat qui a été
promue par la seule députée qui fait
honneur à la république française c'est
à dire martin vos nerfs et au deuxième
tour si jamais ce candidat tiens je veux
qu'à lui en d'accord mais ces gens-là
salon à jean lassalle on adore
bravo fait je voulais donc chacun bosse
parking et au deuxième c'est marine le
pen et macron par contre si j'ose
heymans à savoir ce que ça va voter et
ben non
madame jacobs évident j'adore gens là ça
va ça devrait voter pour lui non merci